[Music]
a year of lockdown forced many of us to
rearrange our priorities and for many
what we really want in our love lives
according to a new survey by kinsey
institute the year of covid set up our
society for a post-pandemic change in
dating norms for singles the
overwhelming majority surveyed
say they're more focused on finding a
serious relationship as a result of the
pandemic
44 say commitment is more important than
before
64 less interested in dating more than
one person at a time
70 percent plan to now video chat before
committing to scheduling a date
and 65 plan on prioritizing finding a
deep connection rather than a hookup
they don't want to date five people at
once you know they
they really want connection which you
know it's not that i mean really think
when you think about how
separate we were from each other and how
you know many people were really afraid
in in deep ways about what this meant
for them
what if they got sick and there was
nobody there for them
on the other hand you had divorces which
rose rapidly in the early days of the
pandemic and have since slowed down over
recent months
wendy strugar says those getting
divorced at the time were couples
already in troubled relationships and
when they were forced to spend more time
at home together and interact more often
she says suddenly there was no escape
and they wanted out of the relationship